hey Collider fans John Roca here glass
hits theaters on January 18th it's the
highly anticipated next installment in M
night Shyamalan eastrail 177 trilogy we
get all the big ones returning for this
one folks Bruce Willis's David Dunn
James McAvoy is Kevin Wendell Crum and
samuel l.jackson Elijah price
aka mr. glass if you've seen the
trailers you know that Sarah Paulsen's
dr. Ellie stapled brings all these dudes
together under one roof and what
transpires looks like all kinds of
bonkers good for you now if you're a bit
rusty or hazy about the previous two
films in the trilogy unbreakable and
split well don't sweat it I got you boo
okay
mm unbreakable started this trilogy off
and it introduces us to Bruce Willis's
David Dunn who spends the whole movie
wandering to be some kind of superhuman
David is a security guard in a dead-end
job heading towards a divorce and losing
the respect of his son Joseph on the way
back from a job interview and NYC he
survives the eastrail 177 train crash
that kills 131 other people but leaves
him without a scratch Jackson's Elijah
price reaches out to David at a memorial
for these victims David and Joseph meet
Elijah at his limited-edition art
gallery get the reference there people
earlier in the film we see that Elijah
suffers from a physical condition called
type 1 osteogenesis imperfecta that
causes his bones to be as brittle as
glass the kids teased him by calling him
mr. glass Elijah's mom encourages him
not to feel sorry for himself and leaves
him a present in a purple gift wrap on a
bench purple that's important people
Elijah opens it up and inside as a comic
book with the words limited edition on
the cover this begins Elijah's love of
comic books
Elijah believes that he is the one to
lead David on a journey to discover his
superhuman abilities because of his love
for comic books these abilities include
superhuman strength his extrasensory
perception brought on by touch and his
invincibility - everything except for
water
remember that David is eventually
convinced he's a hero near the end of
the film when he succeeds at saving a
couple of kids who were tied to a
radiator he discovers this when he
touches a man in the crowd and sees that
that man is the kidnapper he follows the
man to that house and after
almost being drowned by him he fights
him off and kills him
thereby saving the kids inspired by this
act he reconciles with his estranged
wife played by Robin Wright Audrey and
earns back the respect of Joseph when he
points out that it's him they're talking
about in the newspaper now just when
everything is hunky-dory and we're all
feeling good he visits Elijah price at
his gallery as price shakes David's hand
his ESPE kicks in and he sees that price
has masterminded a slew of recent
terrorist attacks including David's
train crash in order to find David as
David recoils in horror price reveals
that he has found his purpose in life he
will be the villain - David's hero and
that you can call him
classic Shyamalan twist gotta love it
all right we had to wait 16 years that's
right people 16 years for a sequel to
unbreakable but damn it was worth the
wait
split a film that looked to be a return
to horror for Shyamalan featured Anya
Taylor Joyce Casey cook being abducted
along with her two classmates Clare and
Marcia by James McAvoy's Kevin Wendell
Crump they are taken deep into the
bowels of the Philadelphia Zoo and are
subjected to Kevin's dissociative
identity disorder or di D Casey and the
girls watch in horror as Kevin and a
number of his personalities come to
visit them at different times in the
movie they each warn of this one
personality that is coming to kill the
girls the Beast he's done awful things
to people and he'll do awful things to
you
I have blue Kevin's personalities
include Barry this British headmistress
named Patricia a super clean freak named
Dennis and an eternal nine-year-old
named Hedwig Kevin physically and
vocally transforms with each personality
and it's creepy a F this guy could be
his own church choir here people he has
so many personalities now kevin is also
treated by Betty Buckley's dr. Karen
Fletcher in the film she introduces the
concept of each personality being
quote-unquote in the light when they are
speaking for Kevin Fletcher is using her
treatment of Kevin as a foundation for a
new approach to treating this condition
she is eventually killed by the Beast
but not before revealing some important
things about Kevin and the source of his
condition Kevin's father left on a train
one day when he was a child and never
came back
leaving Kevin to be terrorized by his
OCD mom then two teenage girls forced
Kevin to touch their breasts when he was
younger all of this eventually triggers
Kevin into unleashing his D ID to
protect him
however Fletcher also reveals that when
you say Kevin's full name he will come
in to the light we also find out through
flashbacks that Casey was sexually
abused by her uncle as a child and that
that abuse continued after her father
died of a heart attack and she was sent
to live with that uncle Ted filthy
animal Casey maintains her cool
throughout the film because of this
experience she does see her chance to
escape later in the film by persuading
Hedwig to bring her to his bedroom to
see his window however the window turns
out to be just a drawing
Henrick does handle walkie
cocky though which case uses to call for
help however patricia takes over and
subdues casey the beast finally appears
and we see Kevin's true superhuman
ability to transform and it is
jaw-dropping the man is scaling walls
people the Beast kills Fletcher and
Casey escapes from her cell to find that
the Beast is eaten Marcia and is
currently eating Claire Casey finds
Fletcher's body and a piece of paper
with Kevin's name on it Casey says
Kevin's full name when he confronts her
and Kevin comes into the light we find
out from Kevin that his actual self has
been buried away from the light for two
years Kevin begs Casey to kill him with
a shotgun he has hidden in a desk drawer
which causes all 24 personalities to
start fighting for the light in a
desperate attempt to stay alive Casey
grabs the shotgun and the ammo and
escapes into a tunnel the Beast
eventually catches up to her she unloads
on him twice with a shotgun to little
effect and as he starts to pull apart
the bars of the cage to get to her he
stops when he notices the scars on
Casey's body she has become a cutter in
order to deal with her uncle's constant
sexual abuse the Beast now considers
Casey to be pure because she has
suffered and runs off leaving Casey
alive
Casey is rescued and we cut to Kevin in
the warehouse talking as Dennis Patricia
and Hedwig about the Beast and their
plans to rid the world of the impure oh
cool finally we cut to a diner playing a
news piece on the rescue of Casey and
here that kevin has been nicknamed the
Horde a woman at the counter struggles
to remember the name of wheelchair-bound
criminal mastermind who also had a
nickname and was incarcerated 15 years
ago as she keeps struggling to remember
the name of voice pipes up and says mr.
glass
and we see that it is david dunn and
this turns split into a sequel to
unbreakable and now we know that all
these characters exist in the same
universe and that there is a reckoning
coming for all of them in glass well
that's all you need to know before you
walk into your local theater to see
glass let us know what you thought of
this video and the movie in the comment
section below
remember to like and share this video on
your social media and subscribe to
collide it quick for more videos just
like this one alright I'm off to go
dance with Hedwig to some kanye west in
this room cuz he thought them yeah in my
room
kanye west is my main man